[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
composer can help you automate your
workflows
quickly cloud composer is a managed
apache airflow service that helps you
create
schedule monitor and manage workflows
composer workflows can connect data
processing and services in google cloud
other public clouds and on-premise
environments
because it is built upon open source
apache airflow
users are free from lock-in and benefit
from the community's
active and rich library of connectors
and plugins
interacting with composer is easy you
can use the cloud console
gcloud command line tool or use the api
with client libraries of your choice
start by creating a composer environment
where you configure your pipeline with
directed acyclic graphs
a dag defines the tasks and dependencies
that are part of your workflow and is
written using python
deploy your workflow and then monitor it
in the airflow ui
and in cloud monitoring use composer to
orchestrate your etl pipelines that
process data in your data warehouse
and data lake or use it to automate
analytics and machine learning jobs
so next time you are looking to
configure and orchestrate workflows
take a minute to look at composer
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
composer
you